hello and welcome to the video playing
proper from Sweden yeah okay place my
own line the Zurich check my own line
but it's the line I had suggested in the
book okay so he just takes them
voluntarily ok so what to do here I have
a g3 base set up or III I think I go to
three in this kind of situation and III
Bishop d3 is running into into 94 so
okay so black has given up the dark
squared bishop but still opts for a
stone wall where the night is on c6 it
is not a story that adds up very well
but what this is a daem a 3 wants to go
a for I guess 495 hmm let's see how to
develop this Bishop f4 it runs right
into a g5 this is something that I
definitely don't want to do right before
might be coming but I don't want to go a
3 as i said i would like to play b3 and
83 but both is difficult to get and
maybe i'll fly and prep move and see
what he does
generally useful move let's aim we were
just Bishop to d7 95 has also moved that
now has become an option before d4 was
hanging so
hmm okay CMC does not have already made
plan him maybe a four is an option for
black
he is connected just taking off of time
more than one and a half minute already
and yeah i fried some of that i was
mentioning already i had mentioned her
night before funky have no good squares
then okay I don't go here which is not
the most ambitious move front but it's a
simple move just cover just have a B
form
hmm yeah what's my plan maybe before Wow
he's taking ages him
it's remarkable
I mean this is not a soup I mean it's
it's slightly unconventional but okay um
this one j h4 or not I guess I go H form
can cal believe in those kind of moves
g5
okay so Knight takes Knight takes 24 23
by the way I don't believe it
on f1 grab before you should just take
this reenter basically say show me it's
not even clear that i have enough here
but i just wanted to do something
directly against this g5 move which yeah
which i should be somehow and punished
probably not with what i play it but
it's definitely something that warrants
punishment
okay I'll just check and check this no
night before okay I'll just just grab
stuff now him can also check here first
yeah this is actually even stronger
double attack him rucca lab resins look
at night yeah I was very strange game
yeah I did started with niobium we
should take C 3 I mean why does all
always spending a tempo to play 3 and
check he just plays it voluntarily and
then sets up the stone wall with the
knight on c6 and we should trade it this
looks really wrong okay I mean hoopty
one is kind of a bit of an equal but I
wasn't quite sure how how to how to
handle the situation didn't see a very
obvious way of playing the engine wants
to take care but I wasn't sure after he
takes what to do while it's always a bit
better but it's not I wasn't so
convinced so okay Rukia a4 yeah okay
Bishop t2 is a bit weaker but not before
he tended me so I just prevented it yeah
I know my age for wolf is probably wrong
LG g5 is really just a weakening move
right I don't think this can be good
this is what the engine is giving 44
normal stuff this is very likely better
and this is probably I just wanted to to
try to punish it but it's probably not
the best objectively
Knight takes 23 the engines has equal
after takes takes 25 okay now I did see
it shows a slight advantage for white
but ok so we had this and this looks
good though right now blacks position is
somewhat crumbling does I the Sun this
must be really bad one yeah this losses
after Bishop takes here he wasn't huge
trend pressure already v6 is best but
it's not a very comfortable position
it's eco material where he's full its
position is full of holes and I've got
to bishop zone the engine is on 1.2 so
it probably didn't matter that much that
he made that mistake ok well thanks for
watching